this is the razor Naboo and in in a
single line we want you to live smarter
with the razor level now what is the
reasonable it's not a SmartWatch it's
not a fitness band but it sits right in
the middle somewhere in between them and
we're calling it a smart band and it
basically does three things really well
it gives you notifications so there's a
there's a public notification screen
right on top of the band that gives you
notifications from your notification
center on iphone or android so whenever
you're getting a called it would be a
call icon showing up right here on the
public notification screen and if you
want to find out more about the
notifications it turn your wrist and
there's a bigger screen on the inside of
your wrist that's a private message
screen the second thing that's really
cool about the reason Abu is that all
the fitness information that you know
from fitness bands work on the Naboo as
well so you're getting all your
information about how many calories you
burn how many steps you've primed hobbit
meters you've walked all that and and it
tracks your sleep patterns so you're
getting all of the full range of fitness
and bio data on the band and the third
thing is that we're keeping the SDKs and
everything about the band to develop for
it very open so developers can use all
the data that we collect on the band and
they can patch their notifications to
the band as well so for example somebody
like RunKeeper could actually use the
data from the band to turn this band
into a runkeeper fitness band so this
releases to developers first after CES
sometime in the middle of quarter one
for forty nine dollars and at the end of
quarter one we want to release it to the
public
you